Freak bitches,
what?
Whatever it is.
Somebody who has thinks they have the
truth with a capital t,
which is called a fundamentalist.
We're all fundamentalists.
You know,
we all have aspects of our personalities
and our belief systems that are
fundamentalist.
If you asked me about sugar,
I'll wax poetic.
I'll tell you all about the evils of
sugar and I really believe I'm right
now.
I have a lot of data and science behind
me,
but I,
I,
you know,
I have all kinds of ideas about why
sugar is bad and fat and proteins.
Good for you because you know,
I've lived in and I've done it.
I'm sure you have your own point of
view.
I had a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
today and it was damn good and it was
damn good and you didn't hurt anybody
including you probably didn't hurt
yourself.
So sometimes because you're not a
fundamentalist because every now and
then.
Thank you.
Thank glass of milk.
Ooh,
was good.
But the little glass of milk I hope is
raw milk,
but I love raw milk.
Raw milk is the shit.
I get the raw cope milk from Erewhon and
go deep,
you know,
you can get to hold,
hold on your horses and I think it's
about $35.
I've never bought it,
but you can get camel milk.
Whoa.
Oh yeah.
What?
Talk about the Middle East.
The Bedouin famed for their sexual
prowess lived on camel milk.
You mean milk?
Like as in titty milk or something?
Cox.
No,
no,
no.
I'm talking about content.
No,
I mean teddy milk milk,
right?
Wink wearing.
No Man.
I'm not talking about Dick Milk.
I'm talking about.
I'm not talking about guide cream.
You're fucking talking about fucking
camel milk from their auditors.
Now.
These Russian cats.
Yeah.
So you were hanging out with in the
Ukraine.
We climbed up on the tower.
There's a lot of those guys.
Yeah.
So a lot of videos.
Like what is it about Russians and
climbing on what,
what is it about these crazy kids and
why they're so nutty?
I don't know.
That's something I've been trying to
figure out.
Like I've,
I've only been to Ukraine.
I haven't been to Russia,
but there's not much.
Like there's not much going on that,
you know,
there's not much to live for in Russia
or Ukraine.
I don't want to sound mean,
but I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
And there's so much that just familiar
with death and violence and stuff like
that.
Like Mustang,
he goes out,
I don't know,
every week and goes like organized
fights,
just like street fights and just beats
the hell out of brandon people.
That to me is like,
so he owned me.
He does those English boy,
those organized treat fights where they
like five guys take on five guys like
big groups.
I've seen those.
Yeah,
he's,
he does that.
And I was like,
what?
So he just does everything crazy.
Yeah.
Wow.
Whoa.
And he just.
Does it offer the thrill?
Yeah,
I think so.
Damn.
What a weird way to live.
I know.
It's a weird way to have your brain
wired.
It was such an interesting kind of
insight when I was there and it'd be
like,
Hey,
take a piss in front of me.
You know how weird that is?
Real weird.
They gotta look at Your Dick,
right?
The other issue I have a rubber Dick.
No,
for real.
So many people have been caught with
those wizard Nader's.
Now what you do is you put bleach under
your finger now or the special.
That's like no advanced.
That's what Joey Diaz says.
Yeah.
She said he put it.
He put clorox under the skin of his
Dick.
He was talking about it.
I one time said he put Draino there too
much.
I used to put coffee on my balls when I
went to court,
the coffee,
I put it in a plastic bag in a rubber
band and wrap it around my school and go
to court.
But he looked like a pimp because it's
going to court every month.
Urine like 50 people in a jail cell.
Right.
And you're just right there and nothing
to do.
I want some coffee on me.
It's like that.
And then everyone was shooting it and
it's like when you're in there,
you want it to be just like this.
Hey man,
there's no responsibility but just to be
cool and be strong and fucking let's
have fun.
Dog.
Wow.
So you knew to keep coffee on your ball
so that you could have it once you'd be
in prison?
No,
this is when I
know that I'm already in prison.
Sometimes you've got to go to court.
So I was going to court to get my
license back because you have the right
to get your license back.
Even though you're in prison,
you still have the right.
So they're like,
all right,
fuck it.
We'll send you.
So I tied it because knowing like eight
or there's not going to be no coffee for
us,
but when I pull up to this and the home
is going to be like because you don't
get in trouble for sneaking coffee.
They'll just like a stupid ass talk shit
to you.
But it was,
it was just like bragging,
having fun.
Right.
Sorry.
That was weird.
Huh?
That's funny though.
That's hilarious.
Thinking about balls and coffee together
and no one's even like,
oh watch out is no one gives a phone
spoon.
Spoon,
Home wise there's,
there's hot water in the restroom at
there.
We'd get it from the sink.
Pretty Weird.
Strange.
When you think about it or does it.